hey everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
abby's kitchen
today i'm trying something new and fun
and this is based on
your suggestion i'm going to be putting
my dietitian hat
on to discuss some of the old-school
diet foods
that some of us may have grown up with
and some of us
i'm looking at you my gen zetters uh may
have never even
tried for yourself but this is gonna be
really really fun
so in this video i'm gonna be looking at
five popular
diet foods of the past some of which are
actually making
quite a bit of a resurgence and i'm
going to discuss
why they were considered diet foods in
the first place the merits of these
claims
based on their nutritional content the
best ways to
enjoy them and what i would score them
out of
10 based purely on their nutritional
merit i really want to reiterate here
that these scores
do not make these good or bad foods
nor do they take into consideration
their value to you
from a flavor economic enjoyment
cultural
or social perspective all of which do
and should play important roles in what
you decide to eat
we know that of course foods are not
created nutritionally equal
but we can make them morally equal so
keep that in mind that if i give one of
your go-to's a less-than-glowing review
i'm not suggesting that you should eat
less of it at all
and if i give something that you dislike
a high score
i don't think that it needs to become a
staple in your diet
i'm just sharing nutrition information
as objectively as i can
keeping in mind also that this is just
one dietitian's appraisal
and you can use that information in
conjunction with all of those other
considerations
when it comes to decisions about what to
eat
okay so on that note my general
disclaimer that the information in this
video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only
and you should always always always
speak to a healthcare provider
about your unique needs also
don't forget to like this video
subscribe and ring that little bell so
that you
never miss out on a video okay so let's
kick things off with the first
diet food that i ever encountered as a
young girl grapefruit
so grapefruit to me could pretty much be
the north american mascot for
diet food and that my friends can be
traced back to a popular 1930s diet
called the grapefruit diet the diet
claimed that you could lose 10 to 12
pounds within 12 days
and relied on the unique enzymes in
grapefruit
to help allegedly burn away fat
this has a special place in my heart
because the grapefruit diet was actually
the first official diet
that i ever went on in grade 10 because
my mom was doing some version of it and
my friend also wanted to try it
well let's just say with only 800
calories a day
i didn't even last a full 24 hours so
yeah
i didn't lose any weight i just got
really hangry the truth is that
grapefruit is a really healthy food
packed with vitamin c
beta-carotene lycopene antioxidants and
flavinones
it also has just a hundred calories and
four grams of fiber in one
whole fruit plus a whole cup of water
having said that it's not a magic weight
loss food that
burns away calories from other foods one
study analyzing the effects of daily
consumption of grapefruit on body weight
and healthy
overweight adults showed that while
grapefruit does have a number of
health benefits related to heart disease
prevention
there were actually no significant
results relating grapefruit consumption
to weight loss specifically i think
grapefruit is fantastic and would be a
great low calorie high fiber nutrient
dense food to add to
any weight loss diet plan if you enjoy
it but it's
not a magic pill so some ways that you
can enjoy grapefruit would be
with some nuts as a snack as part of
your breakfast with some nut butter and
toast
or thrown into a beautiful colorful
salad at lunch
so for its inherent nutrient content
alone
i'm gonna give grapefruit a 9 out of 10.
i honestly can't really fault it for
much other than the fact that it really
won't keep you
that state-shaded for very long next
let's talk about
rice cakes which if you are making a
comeback just judging by
how many people's wedding day videos are
featuring them
but our love of rice cakes really
started back in the 90s when the world
became obsessed
with low fat and low calorie snack foods
and as we've recently seen the pendulum
swing in the opposite direction
we're now seeing them make an appearance
as a vessel to carry
high fat foods like nut butter and
smashed avocado
but let's break down the facts so
rice cakes have only around 35 calories
zero fat and around seven grams of carbs
each so
yes i can see why they're among the top
choice
for dieters and even those in the
fitness community who are counting carbs
as well
but they're free of fiber and free of
protein and you know i'm a huge fan of
snacks with the hunger crushing
compounds
fat protein and fiber rice cakes
unfortunately have
zero of these three they're also not a
major source of any vitamins and
minerals so
translation well even if you're using
these to kind of fill you up for a few
calories
they're not actually going to keep you
full for very long
having said that i actually personally
really like
rice cakes and i'll tell you why for one
there's just something satisfying about
that strange
foamy like crunch especially the
flavored ones that are like
coated in that salt and vinegar
seasoning i legit
lived on those when i had morning
sickness this time around so
i get it i mean if you like them
flavored or otherwise
great i think they're an easy snackable
inexpensive way to get your crunchy figs
but i mainly think of them as like an
easy vessel for
nutrition and for like a spread that
would be more rich
in those hunger crushing compounds that
we just talked about so some ideas on
how to serve a rice cake would be
as a snack top with some avocado and
hemp hearts or
natural peanut butter and some chia jam
or
for a meal you could top it off with
some egg or tuna salad
so i would give rice cakes like a six
and a half out of ten on their own
and a solid eight out of ten when paired
with some more nutritious
dense foods next let's talk about
cottage cheese
the og diet dairy that has since been
eclipsed by greek yogurt in popularity
now north america's obsession with
cottage cheese
actually began in the 1950s and then
peaked in the early 1970s
when the average american ate around
five pounds of it
per year that my friends is a lot of
curds
but one cup of plain two percent cottage
cheese
packs in an impressive 30 grams of
protein
along with calcium phosphorus and
vitamin b12
it's also naturally a low fat cheese so
even though you can find zero one two
and four percent options most readily on
the market
they're all still relatively low calorie
low fat options
we're talking the difference between
like 120 calories
and zero to five grams of fat per half
cup
not really a big deal in my books
there's also lactose free options on the
market for those who can't easily
tolerate dairy so
if that sounds like you try that one out
too the only thing to flag about cottage
cheese
especially as it compares to other high
protein dairy like
greek or obscure yogurt is that it is
naturally high in sodium almost 20
percent of your daily needs in just a
half cup
so if you are sensitive to salt it's
something to watch and maybe keep an eye
on your intake for the rest of the
day or you can try to find a low sodium
option
which only contains around three percent
of your daily salt
so my favorite ways to enjoy cottage
cheese is in a parfait with berries and
nuts
pureed and spread on toast like ricotta
would be with some bananas on top
pureed with some frozen fruit to make my
two ingredient froyo
or pureed into pancake batter to make
protein pancakes
i will leave some links below to some of
my go-to recipes
but i'm going to give cos cheese a 9 out
of 10.
okay now on the topic of breakfast
parfaits
let's talk about granola so here's a
little weak factoid that you can bust
out at your next dinner party
granola was apparently a thing as far
back as the late 1800s
a man named dr james c jackson developed
a cereal like mixture
from gram flour which he named granula
which sounds a lot like how my kid would
probably pronounce granola
but then a decade later seventh-day
adventist director dr
john harvey kellogg created a blend
composed of baked
and re-baked whole grains which he ended
up calling granola
only because he was going to get sued if
he used granula
but anyways a century later granola was
adopted by the modern health food
movement in the 1960s
and to this day is often still called a
hippie health food
again thanks to wellness culture this is
coming full circle
now granola is admittedly kind of hard
to assess from a nutritional standpoint
as there are endless types of varieties
and different ingredients
but let's look at a more mainstream
budget friendly granola store brand
and one that you would find in more
specialty stores
so our grocery store granola is made
with whole grain oat flakes
sugar canola oil and palm oil honey
sunflower seeds and flavor our premium
brand is made with organic gluten-free
oats
organic coconut sugar organic raw virgin
coconut oil
organic sunflower seeds organic puffed
amaranth
organic quinoa flakes organic chia seeds
organic cinnamon
and salt the good news is in both the
first ingredient is
oats and food labeling laws require that
food manufacturers list
ingredients in order of volume meaning
that the first ingredient is present in
the greatest amount in that food product
and the last ingredient is usually found
in very small amounts
i'm not going to get into the organic
difference between these two i mean
because that's a whole preference and
that is a whole other video but
generally you will see some themes here
oats is number one
sugar is the second ingredient in both
of these
some kind of oil is the third and the
rest
is flavors or other nuts seeds or grains
nutrition wise the premium actually has
a lot more calories
fat salt carb and sugar but it also has
more fiber and protein
so it does look like the premium brand
just has more of these nutritious
add-ins which could account for some of
the extra calories
fiber protein and fat and this just goes
to show that lower calorie doesn't
always mean
more nutrient dense and satiating but
we're looking at somewhere between
300 and 450 calories per cup 5 to 20
grams of sugar
5 to 10 grams of protein and 5 to 7
grams of fiber
which you choose would really depend on
your unique health goals
taste preference concern about
ingredient quality like organic or
gluten-free or non-gmo
and of course budget now when it comes
to
cereal the general recommendation is to
look for one with at least 4 grams of
fiber
less than 10 grams of sugar less than
three grams of fat
and less than 360 milligrams of sodium
per serving
so a store-bought granola may meet these
criteria
but as we've seen it also very well may
not
so if you're having a hard time finding
a granola that meets your unique needs
you can easily just make one yourself at
home
i actually have an awesome recipe for
espresso granola in the mindful glow
cookbook which
i'm going to link below but with its
whole grains
nuts and seeds i think that granola is
typically a pretty nutrient-dense food
and because it is more nutrient-dense
and has more calories more sugar more
fat
than let's say a typical breakfast
cereal like all bran or cheerios
you likely aren't going to eat quite as
much
so some ways that i love to eat granola
is to throw it on top of greek yogurt
or if you want to add some nice texture
and flavor to a less exciting breakfast
cereal like bran flakes
you could mix the two together and then
serve with milk
and ideally a milk that's a little
higher in protein like soy
cows or pea it's also delicious as a
handheld snack milk with some popcorn
for an on the go little thing
but i would give granola on average
acknowledging that there are huge
differences
in brands and even if you make it at
home
a generic 6.5 out of 10 strictly from a
nutritional perspective
and let's finish things off with
everyone's favorite
wobbly snack jello so jello has been a
popular american dessert since the late
1800s
yet somehow jello shifted from our
dessert menus
to our diet plans sometime in the 20th
century with the so-called
jello diet proof that you can make a new
popular weight loss diet
simply by limiting the number of foods
that you eat to a narrow selection
anyways proponents of this diet claim
that you can lose 10 to 20 pounds in a
matter of
weeks but let's take a look so jello is
made out of sugar
gelatin aka a protein extracted from the
skin ligaments and bones of animals
artificial flavors some preservatives
and of course
colors jello became a popular diet food
again during the low fat craze
since it is officially completely
fat-free
and in the world of desserts it's also
relatively low in calories with
one serving clocking in at just 80
calories
thankfully we have come a long way since
the 80s
and we now know that fat free doesn't
automatically mean
health food as one serving contains four
and a half
teaspoons of added sugar and not much
else so that means
no fiber not much protein and no
important vitamins or minerals
we also now have sugar-free jell-o which
is sweetened with aspartame
but it still doesn't provide anything
additive nutrition wise
it is also important to briefly touch on
the fact that certain food dyes
contain chemicals that have been linked
to hyperactivity in some children
or allergies in others and one dye in
particular
red 3 has been linked in animal research
to thyroid tumors
jell-o uses red 40 not red 3
as do most red colored food products
today so this is
unlikely to be a huge health concern
having
said that for a lot of people jello is
nostalgic and
is easy to eat especially for those on
texture restrictive diets
and that alone is reason enough to enjoy
it from time to time
and in the grand scheme of desserts
which are not meant to be health foods
in my opinion
just kind of meant to be enjoyed it is a
low calorie option that might satisfy
your mouth
and emotional hunger for something sweet
if it brings you joy
amazing jello it up but if we want to
enjoy jello in a more balanced way that
could boost the nutrition content a bit
we could set the jello with some fresh
fruit or greek yogurt in it
or make your own using fruit or veggie
juice
on its own however speaking purely from
a nutritional standpoint
i would give jello a two out of ten in
conclusion i want to reiterate that
there are no good or bad
foods just more or less nutritious ones
and part of healthy eating is balancing
nutrition with pleasure
but eating any one of these foods that i
ranked highly will not make you healthy
nor will eating any that i did not rank
as favorably
make you unhealthy all of these foods
can
and do fit in a healthy diet if they're
enjoyable for you
so consider all of this information just
another
data point and nothing else and that is
all for today folks i wanted to keep
things sweet and short
but i'd love to know if you liked this
style of video do you appreciate the
more
nutrition heavy information does this
help you make decisions about maybe some
new foods to try to incorporate your
diet
does this give you permission to not eat
certain foods if they don't bring you
joy
let me know by giving this video the
thumbs up if you liked it
leave me a comment below about this
video style or about other classic diet
foods that you'd like to see me review
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye